now so many in our community continue to
look for good paying jobs
but we wanted to know which areas of the
economy are hiring and where you may
have the most luck if you're out there
looking
the i-team's david charns here now with
one hot sector and david
apparently it's not surprising when we
think about just how much money we all
spend online these days right i mean
we are talking amazon here specifically
the number of people working in the
company's massive warehouses
and the ones then delivering all your
orders to your house
it's an industry that's helping our
economy rebound
and one where some in hospitality and
tourism
are actually finding success
it's go time here at this amazon
warehouse in henderson
the final stop before that package hits
your doorstep in a place where more and
more southern nevadans are choosing to
work
i think that the pandemic definitely
fueled the increase in the amount of
e-commerce and deliveries
within all sectors you could say it not
only fueled orders
but our local job market amid a global
pandemic
amazon added 10 thousand jobs in nevada
alone
in 2020. unfortunately with everything
that happened with covid and the
pandemic
my position was eliminated every night
we'll send all the packages right back
down from the dock doors
hiring people like matt resnick who came
to amazon
as an operations manager from the
hospitality industry
running large teams working with people
working with customers
important skills whether running a team
in the halls of a hotel
or the aisles here at amazon the i-team
looked at
employment data from 2019 the year
before the pandemic began
to now since then the job sector trade
transportation and utilities
which encompasses retail warehouses the
one that includes jobs like resnicks
here at amazon
saw the most growth the biggest loss
hospitality
losing more than 80 thousand jobs
compared to 2019. there's been a lot of
leisure and hospitality employees that
have been
sitting on the sidelines since the start
of the pandemic some have come back
a significant number of come back but we
have a long way to go
brian gordon is an economist at applied
analysis
he says a lot of hospitality jobs
haven't come back yet
because tourism hasn't fully rebounded
international restrictions and the lack
of booming conventions
means we're just not there yet so those
segments of the market are really
holding back
i think the tourism economy here in
nevada i didn't at first think that
hospitality might blend with that
but when i started reading more into
some of the job descriptions i really
found that
you know it's all about leading large
teams engaging your employees
employees like resnick have made the
jump turning the corner
and trying something new without waiting
and by year's end
amazon plans to open five more
warehouses
meaning thousands of more openings each
of those sites will have more employees
new employees more more people to hire
all right so let's take a look at where
jobs are being added right now this is
over the past three months and it's from
our friends over at applied analysis
you see the growth here of course
leisure in hospitality that's where jobs
are being added right now the past
couple months
professional business services and of
course then trade transportation
utilities three thousand jobs added in
the past three months alone now remember
just because the numbers are lower than
they were this doesn't mean these
other industries aren't adding jobs it
just means that where the growth is now
is in these other places because we are
all dealing with the bounce back
after this pandemic